في النرويج ممرات بحريه تخترق اعماق
اليابسه تعد كنوزا حقيقيه طبيعيه بالنسبه
للسكان هنا ومصدر رزقهم الاول من خلال
خدمه السفن والبواخر الماره عبر الممر
الملاحي
مضيق ترونس هايم البالغ طوله 130 كيلومترا
استخدمته شعوب الفايكنج لنقل الرجال
والبضائع وما زال صامدا حتى اليوم رغم
مساحه سطح المضيق التي تقل بسبب العبور
المكثف للعبارات المائيه
[موسيقى]
ففي لحظه تثور العواصف والرياح ويصبح
خطيرا جدا لذلك رجال الانقاذ يقومون هنا
بدوريات منتظمه لانقاذ البحاره المعرضين
للخطر المفاجئ
[موسيقى]
الممر المائي هو طريق رئيسي
الى مدينه
طفي عصور الفايكنج تم قطع رؤوس الخونه
وغرست بشكل واضح على اوتاد عند مدخل
المضيق ليعلم الجميع اهميه هذا الممر
طول مضيقي ليست في سطح مياهه فقط فهناك في
القاع كنوز اخرى محفوظه يعرفها الغواصون
الذين يجرؤون على المغامرات في هذه المياه
الجليديه
[موسيقى]
سواء على سطح المياه امثله اعماقها سكان
هذا المضيق محظوظون ولديهم اسباب واجهه
للوقوع في حب هذا المكان والدفاع عنه منذ
قدم التاريخ
[موسيقى]